hi how are you
well thanks um listen I know we don't
have an appointment I know you guys are
busy but we would love if someone could
just leave a message for lead of global
product policy and active channels
specialist we just wanted to talk with
them about their their new guidelines
are okay for Google okay which floor is
that okay we're out there you know they
have these new guidelines I know at
YouTube and Google if they would like to
grab some time I know they're busy and
discuss it will be out here specifically
kind of the new hate speech guidelines
that people little iffy on my name is
steven crowder was part of a kind of a
controversy recently and just wanted to
sit down and talk about if i see those
names or time sure yeah the great head
of global product policy and she's the
active channel specialist okay i cannot
promise that they're even here but okay
I can see what I can do okay I'll let
them know that you're here if they are
here okay yeah do you come back out and
rally up some information whenever you
get it that'd be great we'll just be
right outside so for this installment
have changed my mind I decided to set up
shop right outside of Google offices in
Austin Texas with my half-asian lawyer
bill Richman to revisit the topic of
hate speech and see if we could get some
answers from the powers that be and we
did have some interesting and productive
discussions it being legal or illegal
I'm not sure but like there definitely
is some form of hate speech like that
definitely exists I think would you
qualify as harmful speech and that's
that's a Harper to different is
what is that boomer you crossed the line
for this top of the page speed separate
setting aside our views we can at least
agree let's get some clarity from these
platforms on what the rules are
I would also strongly support you know
others right to be eminently opposed
what you're doing you know by almost any
means necessary
maybe with force you know I'm not
advocating violence you're not loose if
I almost any means no us any means yeah
things like that I fully support
combating by any means necessary
that means violence yeah even this
Austin legends stop by but more on that
later I want to note that something
interesting happened here not only did
nearly everyone find themselves
ultimately agreeing with us on the idea
of hate speech though actually I agree
with you I agree with that people want
that to be illegal it's just someone's
opinion government regulated no no
definitely not I don't think we just
agree in a whole lot that makes sense
yeah is there anything there with which
this tech companies are very sleazy
yes they are is that fair yeah I agree
but more than ever before people seemed
legitimately concerned and they really
pressed us for some answers to these
concerning questions since they had a
legal expert with me we decided to do
something a little different and conduct
an impromptu public Q&A session on hate
speech in the current state of free
speech online I wonder to myself is it
really in the wrong for a private
company such as Google or YouTube to
shut down a channel that they don't like
because it is a private company so I
wonder that sometimes I mean I don't
want his channel to get shut down but I
also believe in capitalism and if they
don't like it then they should you know
be able to shut it down so what what do
you say about that well that's that's
directly on point with the topic right
and the question is I'll say two parts
one what are the what are the ability of
companies to be able to take certain
action and
and should they be able to take certain
action so right now with private
companies within their own private
businesses and even within their own
private platforms that Stephen has
always said they have the ability to
make certain restrictions this is kind
of the debate between publishers and
platforms like are you a Content neutral
provider like a telephone company right
you're not gonna go and say oh well AT&T
needs to be shut down or their
executives need to go to jail because
someone was planning a murder over a
telephone right but by the same token
these platforms have come in and decided
that they want to actually do more and
they want to regulate the type of speech
which makes them kind of not being just
content neutral like a telephone company
or something like that
the separate question is so generally
they do they have the right to be able
to say these are the rules I think for
some of you who have followed the Vox
issue recently the big question is not
does YouTube have the right to enforce
certain rules it's what are the dang
rules right and that's something all
creators whether you like conservative
views or you're against conservative
views you're pro-lgbt
you have questions about the LGBT
movement if there are no rules that
means they can be enforced against
anyone and and that is one of the
biggest questions and one that remains
unanswered so the second question is
should then right and for that I would
actually say the ACLU is one of the best
organizations in terms of setting out
why companies like YouTube and Facebook
and Twitter should follow First
Amendment restrictions and the reason is
is because it stops chilling free speech
like if you really want to be a company
that operates in a democracy that really
values equality and the rights that we
have in this country then you should
operate your policies in a way that is
more like the First Amendment and the
First Amendment only has at least how
it's been articulated in this country
you only have certain things the
emergency principle there's a direct
harm a direct serious incident that's
going to happen something that's
immediately gonna happen crying fire in
a crowded movie theater when there is no
fire right directing someone to go and
actually cause harm to someone else
that's already regulated and we would
say that that should continue to be
regulated by social media platforms or
really any company whatsoever
and then the second thing being whether
or not it should be viewpoint-neutral
should a government should someone wake
up one day and say you know what I don't
like that guy
kanima bar him from the world right he's
out not because it's actually dangerous
because if it was already dangerous it
would already be banned but to say this
is the view I find it too offensive
let's shut it down so when the question
of should they the question is
definitely no they should adopt a policy
that is more like the actual free speech
structure that we have in this country
as opposed to ones that they have in
other countries so you're saying like
defining defining what the parameters
are and then applying them to everyone
not just stations that they find
disagreeable exactly so viewpoint
neutrality I mean that's the point is is
it who is going to decide in this day
and age what the views are that are
offensive or not offensive I mean my
sheer existence as the product of a
interracial marriage is something that
is not too long ago 50 60 70 years ago
was considered offensive vile leading to
anger leading to discourse that would
create a public nuisance and so those
the very laws that we are trying to
support right now and say is the right
structure are the same laws that allowed
for that type of speech or expression to
occur for people to be able to have and
say interracial marriage is okay and
some people may still believe that it's
not okay and again whether or not
someone believes that that's right or
not obviously I sit here and I think
it's okay but if someone doesn't think
it's okay it's not agreeing with them to
say that they should have the right to
be able to say
anakata
so it becomes the type of action that
they're engaged in and whether or not
they're actually you know taking it it's
a it's a grayscale it's a continuum and
what seems to be clear is that they're
falling more and more towards the sides
of publishers who are actually selecting
the content as opposed to just carriers
who are just letting things happen the
way that they're going and I and I get
it it's it's not to say that that isn't
a model that's worth having but like
Steven said it's a matter of just being
open right be open with the people who
are gonna devote time and money who are
gonna spend money on the platforms in
advertising be honest with them about
what you actually want your platform to
be part of it might be they just don't
actually even know what they want it to
be right there they had I invested
themselves in the time to decide how do
we want to approach this and they've
kind of been forced to that question and
when forcing that question recently they
find that none of Steven's videos have
violations
kind of like Burma antitrust and point
saying if your point
you're gonna be the road well there's
there's definitely some questions about
anti-competitive behavior right now the
Department of Justice and the FTC are
both conducting separate investigations
into different social media and Silicon
Valley companies over concerns some of
those are related to First Amendment
issues others of those are related to
just how they conduct their businesses
and what becomes a question is is if you
have a company that says hey this is how
we're gonna run our business we are
going to be the business of publishing
data we're gonna get together with other
publishers to decide a competitor of
ours can no longer do this or you decide
then channels that compete with let's
say Stevens Channel you're gonna all get
together to decide well okay now you
can't compete in this marketplace with
the other ones because we've decided to
employ the guidelines but then you don't
even say what the violations are that
does raise questions of antitrust
violations are you engaged in an actual
fair play that the antitrust statute is
what we're trying to have with that type
of law
artist was about what they are and
whether they
when they see
so two separate things there versus the
anta truck they can still be in a
competitive while being expressed right
you can still go out and say I'm gonna
destroy your business I'm mr.
Rockefeller etc and bury you right
that's still could be anti-competitive
but separately on the question of
whether or not creators are actually
coming to the platform and users are
supporting the platform with their eyes
and their subscriptions is to be honest
about how are you actually going to
apply it and we're not because everyone
here whether you're on one side or the
other side of the debate you just want
to know am i supporting a person on
their views or they're not when they
continually hide behind is a policy
that's I think maybe a page and a half
long with a bunch of words that are
undefined and when asked impressed for
examples they won't give them so it
becomes a concern it's it's the issue of
not understanding the rules and not
understanding the guidelines and the
only statement that's been affirmed
that's been put out there that there was
no violation of guidelines so what do
you you know what do you do with that
something else I think people might want
to anyone here planning on being any
kind of a content creator does anyone
here work in media or want to be doing
something like that okay so you go so
too young examples so you probably
obviously would assume that YouTube is a
place to go right how old are you 20 and
18 okay
so let's be honest right YouTube is
really the only game in town as far as
that now that wasn't always the case
we've talked about this before while
we're talking sort of about antitrust
now I'm not a lawyer I can defer to Bill
after this but when we started on
YouTube right for example my brother and
I did a video in 2006 there were other
competitors there was I think Vimeo
liveleak but YouTube was the first place
to offer to pay people right now hey
listen if you post your videos an arc on
our platform if you use our platform not
necessarily exclusively but if you make
us our primary platform we will pay you
and you'll be able to make a living and
then a special neighbor purchased by
Google we were some of my brother was
one of the first to YouTube partners
ever right back in 2006 or 2007 whenever
they launched the program he was a part
of the launch and then these competitors
folded why because they couldn't afford
to compete they couldn't pay creators
YouTube had been losing money for a very
long time this is important to know so
they build up their platform they hit
critical mass and like you said as it's
20 year old you probably have never
known a world where YouTube wasn't the
primary video player well they built
that by paying people by inviting people
to create
content on their platform under the
guise of them being paid and being able
to start a business other competitors
folded now YouTube is saying the very
same people the very same content that
built our platform and made us the
biggest media portal in the on the web
we're gonna change all the rules and get
rid of you so eliminate competition with
one practice and then switch it once the
competition is eliminated that's a
concern as well for anyone who wants to
create content because now YouTube
either buys up other entities or they
simply can't compete and that's maybe
something that bill could speak to more
but that's certainly been in my
experience and other creators who have
been there since the beginning if you're
choosing to start out you're gonna want
to know what are you actually starting
out with again the question continually
for any creator of any viewpoint whether
your material even has a viewpoint right
maybe you're just a makeup tutorials
right but you want to know I mean the
best time and money on this platform
where am I going to get out of it what
are the rules I'm actually playing by in
this particular situation quick heads up
if you enjoy change my mind and you want
more of this kind of content please do
support us by joining my club at ladder
with credit com / mug Club ninety-nine
dollars annually 69 for student veterans
active military you get a full daily
show that you don't see here on YouTube
along with access to the entire blaze TV
catalog
now you'll see the questions from the
crowd shifted from general curiosity to
how we got here in the first place
asking in relation to box and like I
guess traditional lefty media like CNN
MSNBC yeah or they like on the same side
like do you think MSNBC CNN they are
really that interested in like bringing
you down like boxes do you think they're
just as aggressive like this is a big
plan or box is just taking this like way
too far the try to say well it is odd to
me that not only an atlas and I don't
want to be a martyr with this but they
were the ones who drew first blood not
me it is odd that the moment this guy
cuts together you know there's a super
cut from six years of content completely
out of context that it goes to boombox
for advice CNN MSNBC New York Times you
know all these major publications and
something interesting too we found out
only after the fact Washington Post like
right away wrote a piece they already
had done an interview with people from
Vox send it to me at six o'clock at
night and said by the way have an hour
to answer before the piece goes live and
it was sent through my merch site like
there's a contact form on the website
for press inquiries so they were very
deliberate in making sure that one side
of the story was presented and I don't
know as far as all of media but listen
box is owned by NBC Universal right they
put in two hundred million dollars
they're a billion dollar company and
it's no secret that we do the only
conservative late-night show you know
it's available online and listen I'm
very grateful this isn't something that
we brag about it's something that I'm
grateful for now we are higher
significantly higher numbers and Seth
Meyers and we're approaching the numbers
of their people like I think NBC's Jimmy
Fallon or their subsidiary networks they
don't like that you know so I can't say
all of media at large
but this is definitely a fight between
independent content creators and giant
media and when you look at YouTube what
they said is they're now going to push
more authoritative news sources in
someone's feed meeting let's say you
like my videos or let's say you like
someone like I don't know
Philip DeFranco whoever it is they're
going to say hey instead will suggest
CNN or NBC or Washington Post or New
York Times YouTube has said that they've
declared them authoritative why are they
authoritative sources because YouTube
declared themselves right and that's
sort of a circular game that occurs with
traditional media it's like well this is
my reference and it's legitimate well
why is it legitimate because I'm at the
Washington Post I'm using that as my
reference okay but you use them as a rep
yes that's what makes them legitimate
and that happens a lot so that's the
concern obviously you see a concerted
effort from NBC and it's all of its
subsidiary networks and who knows who
knows where this ends up but they
certainly do want to squash that
independent content creators and not
even just political ones you know that's
how you see they've targeted us a comedy
channel and now other history channels
you know and gaming channels that's a
real a real concern yes
and no it is just a lot of things get
published don't really know if it's
unbiased or not what are like some of
the
that you recommend
you're researching yes or what not a
good question I actually recommend the
most biased source as possible so every
morning I read Huffington Post salon
watch Young Turks Washington Post I have
a subscription New York Times I want to
see what the left is saying and then
it'll read some conservative news
sources but I would say our show is
different from a lot of conservative
news shows because we're usually
addressing the issue that the mainstream
Left media focuses on and not what other
conservative media tends to focus on
they're kind of two different worlds
there's a bit of a chasm there so I
would encourage everybody what I just do
is set some bookmarks here's the thing
this is it's a myth the idea of and I
know some people don't necessarily agree
with me on this the idea of once
objective journalism they like the era
of Walter Cronkite if you read quotes
from Walter Cronkite he said I don't
think you can be a journalist and not be
a liberal for a portion of time people
thought Walter Cronkite was my god an
actual journalist right there was never
a golden era of unbiased journalism you
just weren't able to fact check it we
just believed it just like up until the
most recent election it what Fox News
was seen as right MSNBC was seen as left
and CNN was seen as Center does anyone
believe that CNN is Center anymore
no of course not and so I think the best
that you can do is accept that human
beings have an inherent bias and read
from at least openly bias sources so
read from sources that you know are
coming from a left-wing point of view
read from sources that you know are
coming from a right-wing point of view
juxtapose them and decide where you line
up as opposed to trying to find a more
unbiased authoritative source because
frankly and having worked in this
industry for a long time it doesn't
exist I think one of the things to keep
in mind the first side I check every
morning it's slate which maybe 10 years
ago was a little more centric but has
definitely been a decidedly and openly
more leftist type platform but it's the
first one I do because it's the one
that's challenging the ideas that I
already have and so if you're not
willing to have your ideas challenged if
you're not willing to sit in the seat
and answer the tough questions you're
not going to be ready to answer them
when someone else wants it to be that
when they come to you with your ideas
you won't be ready to so what I do is I
read those articles I go through and I
fact-checking myself right and that
requires more work that requires more
engagement I mean sometimes I'll fact
check them and I'll type in the topic
and I'll look at a couple different news
sources most of the time you can go look
at the actual study go
the actual quote most of the time
they're not even a source right so
you're having to figure out what those
things are and it's that it's that type
of kind of investigation that will give
you maybe a little bit of a jaded eye
but I'd say a more critical eye of any
source you're looking through and to get
more to that nugget of truth that is out
there and frankly it's all a little bit
gray it's all a little bit gray very
rarely is either one these gonna be just
spot-on
whether it's statistics or facts and
especially what now is counting as
journalism is frankly just a lot of
opinions so what can regular citizens do
to combat combat like YouTube censoring
people and the social media companies
like taking voices away sure well I
think appreciate a couple before we go
to legal issues no I think it's
important Linney a between like
censorship which is obviously government
and right now private businesses and
platforms our issue is not as we don't
necessarily call it censorship it is
corporate censorship and that there
capitulating the people who intimidate
them as far as what people can do I mean
the biggest thing you can do is make
your voice heard on these platforms and
support the voices that you see is being
silenced you know so that's that's why
we've created like obviously mugs up I'm
not this isn't just a plug if people
want to support us great if they don't
they don't have to and then of course
kind of keep an eye out legally right
now there gonna be some pretty big seems
like what are they lawsuits are they
just legal probes in the antitrust so
government has a facility an ability to
be able to investigate antitrust so
they're in taking their own
investigation as well through the
Department of Justice and the Federal
Trade Commission so those are two
different parts of Silicon Valley and
social media that are being investigated
for anti-competitive behavior separate
and apart from that you can take action
based on not only your actual voice and
stuff you do in the stuff you view but
but also directly in complaining to
these various folks I mean obviously
we've seen through the Carlos maza
example that YouTube is sitting there
listening when they want to listen and
so they'll eventually listen to someone
and enough voices that say hey we may
don't we may not like certain things
we've offended by certain things but we
want all these people to be able to say
it and while you're not required to do
it right now as a private company we're
asking that you do it if you want to
continue to be the successful company
well yeah
how many people anyone here have
actually seen some of the rebuttals that
we've done to Vox is content by show of
hands okay so a few people so you know
that these videos are substantial
rebuttals to Vox and then yeah there's
some stuff tossed in that's obviously
humour and sometimes I don't even
necessarily plan what we say but a good
example there is I'll watch a Vox video
all the way through I'll say well hold
on a second I know that's not right I
know that's not right in the problem
with Vox is they often don't list their
sources so they'll list maybe some kind
of or they'll mention an original source
and then they'll have a quasi expert on
to validate the source they haven't
provided for you they've been provided
at least a tangible reference or they
often use charts sort of based on
multiple sources so the process will be
I have to sit down and watch Vox and I
sit down usually with I have one guy who
is a brilliant researcher who helps with
us that you have to do it all about
myself thank God for mug Club because
now we can hire more people to help with
this but I'll wash and gohan second he
just made a claim but there's no source
for that claim reverse-engineer it where
is he getting this claim typically I'll
go to HuffPo slate salon liberal sites
type in a similar claim you know
cross-reference it find their claim
often there's no original source there
go to that source and then see what I
believe to be wrong with that source and
if you look at the sources that we try
to provide on our show it'll be for
example from pub pub bad you know and
NCBI is the website we try to avoid
using sources that would be from let's
say you know like redstate.com
or Fox news.com we'll use those if we're
specifically commenting on opinion or
commenting on something someone said
from that website but we try to go to
the original source material and with
Vox with all of the money and all the
research you know and they accuse us of
our content being easier the fact is the
most difficult part is often parsing the
non-existent sources from places like
Vox and so it's required us to have a
team of people everyone here I mean if
you can just give a round of applause to
everyone here that everyone working up
Tim Manny you have Bryce yeah get
quarterblack Garrett like there's most
the pride-swallowing siege that is our
job that I will never fully tell you
about is trying to reverse engineer some
time sources that do not exist and it's
something that I recommend everyone do
in their daily life and you don't have
to obvious after rebut entire box video
but your antenna will go up sometime
when your
more leftist sources or sources the
challenge and sometimes you'll find that
you actually agree with them but I do
think that's really important this idea
that and this is sorry now I'm gonna I'm
kind of ranting this has nothing that
says isn't exactly doesn't have to do
with this but did you see the New York
Times article the making of a radical
anyone see that article that went up
there turns out the guy wasn't actually
turned into a radical he was a
conservative who then went to college
became a liberal and then started dating
a Christian conservative afterward and
ended up being a liberal in the anyways
doesn't matter whose front page New York
Times my face is right on there as
alright apparently Milton Friedman too
but the point here is the argument they
were making for example was that YouTube
if you look at YouTube is all about
engagements and so YouTube radicalizes
people by suggesting content for you to
watch that might be more radical but the
truth is with YouTube and how many
people here use YouTube I would argue
and this is one thing and this is why
it's so odd the traditional media is
attacking YouTube right as clickbait I
will put for example this change my mind
will go up on YouTube it will get
millions of plays it will go up on
Facebook will be lucky to get 50,000
plays but someone can post a meme
conservative meme that says hillary's
should be locked up click like if you
agree a million shares
we found that Facebook and Twitter these
are these are places that can be
manipulated using their algorithms and
really apply themselves well to
clickbait but on YouTube right everyone
your who want uses YouTube it doesn't
work how many times have you actually
clicked on a video on YouTube with a
clickbait title and it's not what you
expected how many times has that ever
happen any of you yeah what happens the
next time you see that channel you never
see it again
YouTube is the opposite of clickbait you
can't cheat an hour-long change my mind
with people watching for 92% they either
want to watch or they don't you can't
cheat title Vox rebuttal people either
want to watch it or they don't so it's
so odd to me that they are attacking
YouTube as creating this radicalization
or these enclaves of radicalization it's
so odd to me that they're going after
YouTube when really you cannot cheat
long-form video content it is the truest
form of content in new media it's kind
of like stand-up is the closest thing to
purity in traditional media outside of a
film or television like stand-up you're
either funny or you're not
YouTube either people want to watch the
video or they don't it's not like
Facebook it's not like Twitter it's not
like Instagram it's just a bunch of
fitness models but YouTube is great
YouTube is where people get information
actually engage in a long time
content and that's the one that they
want to they want to tar and feather and
shut down and that's why it's so odd and
concerning to me and I think if you go
through your own sort of mental
inventory take your inventory right now
kind of mentally and go what do I do on
YouTube none of you guys are getting
clicked baited on YouTube on a regular
basis I guarantee you that's not how
YouTube works but that's the argument
that big media is using to try and shut
down voices they disagree with they want
to say that this right here is either
hateful bigoted incendiary or clickbait
it's none of those things so watch the
content for yourself what questions most
concern you as it relates to big tech
hate speech in the current state of the
First Amendment leave your thoughts in
the comment section and remember next
Monday we will be releasing the full
more traditional change my mind on the
topic of hate speech which holds more
than a few surprises I would never
encourage no I'm not scared of
Milkshakes I think someone who throws a
milkshake of the Pepsi as a
transgendered woman that's a man I'm a
transgender woman that's a man as well
do you see the new interview with sundar
pichai and that space-alien person where
they admit they're censoring everybody
did you see that the hell are you
talking about